NARRATOR: Deep in the
Ozark Mountains, the pickup
is rigged for a heavy haul.
Here goes nothing.
NARRATOR: To move a repurposed
shed to its new home,
in a clearing 100 feet
away, if it holds.
Looks good.
Are you happy
with where it is?
I like it.
JASON: Yeah?
I'll be damned.
All right, high five.
It worked.
Everything worked out
better than I'd hoped for.
Now I've got to get on
building some laying box
for these chickens.
NARRATOR: To keep the chickens
safe in their new coop,
they're installing a fence.
JASON: And Mary's
gonna get on the fence,
so that they're safe
and secure at night.
NARRATOR: And nesting
cubbies for laying eggs.
The boxes themselves, just a
bunch of scrap wood that I knew
would come in handy
for something.
[clanging]
Mary's got her hands
full with the little one,
and working on the fence.
With the fencepost
pounder, I'm
going to pound in a post
on each corner of the yard.
This is just get a
quick something up,
so they won't escape tonight.
[hammering]
All right.
That's the bottom
through here.
Mary's got the fence done.
River's back from school.
And only, really, one
thing left to do, bring
in these lovely chickens
and introduce them
to their new glorious home.
All right, so, River?
Yeah?
JASON: I'm gonna trim
the feathers back a bit,
so that they don't fly.
And you get to name them.
Yay.
NARRATOR: Trimming the primary
flight feathers on at least one
wing keeps the birds grounded.
Yeah, that's good.
Let her go.
There's number one.
Who's that?
Spots.
Spots, OK.
Hello, Spots.
JASON: Chickens cannot
fly for a long distance,
but they can fly.
So by trimming their wings,
they're not gonna fly off.
Let's get that.
[chicken clucking]
Yup, there you go.
Who's that?
- Sleepy.
All right, watch your fingers.
Go.
Steve.
Steve?
Steve the chicken.
I like Steve.
Come on.
JASON: Mary and I
have made a plan,
and together we pulled this off.
And now we've got chickens.
And they ought to
start laying soon.
It's an added source of protein.
And it's also an
added source of meat.
So they're one more
thing to this homestead
that makes it feel like home.